especialmente cuando los chicos adultos
vírgenes son ridiculizados y les dicen
cosas como que porque no tienes novia no
te vas a casar pronto ahora es un
incierto
bueno
[Música]
el sexo oral cuenta cómo perder la
virginidad
321 ahora
quiero decir creo que lo llamamos sexo
oral por una razón porque obtienes los
mismos beneficios de la boca de alguien
que cuando tienes coito vaginal entonces
si es sexo creo que estoy de acuerdo
contigo porque cuando creces crees que
eso es el sexo verdad todo el acto
completo pero lo que dices tiene sentido
ya que llegas al mismo objetivo así que
me pondré por acá escucharlos decir esto
me hace repensar lo un poco siempre ha
asumido que es solo la penetración pero
es así y eso es lo que pensé sí es decir
para mí perder la virginidad sería
recibirlo por mi parte trasera no sé si
saben a lo que me refiero pero esta es
mi propia definición personal de lo que
es la virginidad para mí tengo miedo de
tener sexo
321 ahora
eso me da miedo dijiste que si tengo
miedo no si
entonces definitivamente no
en realidad pienso algo como esperen
esperen que ustedes le tienen miedo al
sexo yo conozco mi camino me casaré
tendré sexo con mi esposa y será genial
no tengo ningún miedo sobre eso en
absoluto siento que exponerte en tu
forma más cruda de otro ser humano aquí
en una máquina más y bueno cierto y
quién me a entonces pero no estás para
nada incluso nervioso no en absoluto te
hablo escuchen es decir en este momento
estoy aquí hablando así que no sé cómo
serán cuando llegue el momento pero si
sucede con una persona a la que amo y
hemos salido nos conocemos y sabemos
cómo funcionamos la comunicación es
clave no estaría bastante cómodo en
general siento que sería extremadamente
incómodo así que si me da un poco de
miedo pero
mente no tengo miedo de perderla con la
persona equivocada porque no importa lo
que pretenda siento que no será algo
monógama pero tal vez tengo miedo de que
esa persona no sea con quién se supone
que debe estar para siempre pero el
resto de me veo que mucha de esa presión
viene de la pornografía porque pinta una
imagen en tu mente que al menos el 90%
del tiempo no se puede cumplir o
satisfacer entonces si voy a tener sexo
con ella espera un iphone 12 pro max y
todo lo que tengo es un 12 mini sabes
eso es lo que algunos chicos piensan
verdad sienten que no pueden cumplir con
esos estándares porque en su mayor parte
es falso te escuché susurrar que no te
importa y sentir lo mismo yo también
creo que a la persona adecuada no le
importaría tal vez simplemente tenemos
demasiado tiempo para pensar en estas
cosas y nos presionamos demasiado por
alguna razón para lucir o actuar de
cierta manera y lo descubriremos cuando
sea el momento adecuado entonces por qué
malgastar nuestro tiempo preocupándonos
por eso tal vez estoy un poco menos
asustado ahora
y
me estoy reservando para el matrimonio
321 ahora
reservarme para el matrimonio fue algo
que me enseñaron mientras crecía fue
algo muy adoctrinado en mi mente
entonces ya saben a una edad temprana
tomé esa decisión no quiero darle esa
parte de mí a nadie que no vaya a
embarcarse en ese viaje conmigo creo que
el intercambio de energía entre mi
futura esposa y yo será tan poderoso que
cuando nos casemos solo anhelar hemos
ese momento y sé que en los próximos
años después de eso tendremos
simplemente gran sexo una y otra vez
solo porque he esperado ese momento y
será algo especial para mí yo no he
estado en una relación y no estoy segura
de cómo actuaría estando en una por eso
estoy en la línea de simplemente estoy
de acuerdo porque me encantaría
reservarme para el matrimonio eso es lo
que pretendo en este momento pero
tampoco he salido con nadie ni he tenido
alguna relación así que no sé cómo
actuaría no sé si ese será mi primer
amor o qué tipo de presión habría sobre
mí por eso no estoy totalmente de
acuerdo
a muchos hombres te han invitado a salir
o han intentado salir contigo sí pero
normalmente escapo porque tengo miedo y
si es así que te hace huir como es que
pues pienso que fue mi mentalidad de
este joven de tenerle miedo a los
hombres en general solo porque quedar
embarazada en donde crecí era normal a
una edad temprana así que nunca quise
que me pasara a mí al igual que ella
tengo cero experiencia en relaciones
excepto que a mí nadie me pidió que
saliera con ellos otra cosa conveniente
para mí al salvar mi virginidad hasta el
matrimonio es que ya saben hubo una
desafortunada ocasión en la cual
una chica me maltrato sexualmente cuando
era joven no entendía en ese momento que
no era algo bueno sino hasta más
adelante y eso me hizo muy protector y
selectivo
yo solía tener esa mentalidad de querer
esperar hasta el matrimonio cuando era
más joven y por alguna razón eso era lo
que quería no crecí en un hogar
religioso donde eso fuera algo que se
esperara y fue solo una decisión que
quería tomar pero creo que luego comenzó
a evolucionar hacia cuando me sienta
cómoda cuando sienta que es alguien con
quien quiero tener esa experiencia pero
no quería que fuera como una casilla que
necesitara rellenar antes de querer
tomar esa decisión yo disfruto ver porno
321 ahora
bien pues técnicamente la fotografía
libera dopamina así que todos la
disfrutamos pero es después de hacer lo
que te das cuenta de lo horrible que es
estás viendo a dos personas tener sexo a
través de un teléfono en el baño es un
poco repugnante llevo más de 1000 días y
masturbación no he visto porno más de
mil días yo estuve expuesto a eso como
los 10 años no es natural no es
saludable
e intento no mirarla pero cuando la veo
la disfruto así que debo ser honesto con
ustedes pero realmente he intentado no
masturbarme sabes pero no estoy a 1000
días ni nada de eso yo creo que ver
pornografía es una experiencia muy
privada quiero decir no es como que
salgamos y digamos oigan y veo porno yo
veo el hecho de ver pornografía como una
salida para mi frustración sexual siento
que me ayuda a mantener mi virginidad ya
que no he tenido sexo ni lo he
experimentado para mí ha sido casi como
una herramienta para aprender y
comprender cómo funciona el sexo ya que
nunca tuve clases de educación sexual ni
de salud ni de nada de eso hay
diferentes tipos de pornografía saben
algunas son más románticas y naturales
eso creo y otras son
un poco locas hay algo de belleza en
algunas que las hacen más naturales como
sería en la realidad no creo que sea del
todo malo entonces crees que lo que ves
en vídeos porno es como la gente tiene
sexo en la vida real no no en la mayoría
pienso mucho en tener sexo
321 ahora
[Música]
por un tiempo pensé que algo andaba mal
conmigo porque nunca pensaba en eso no
es algo que haya surgido nunca siempre
supe que era un poco diferente ya que
nunca pensé ni quise pensar en eso la
verdad es que siento lo mismo yo también
pensé que algo andaba mal y uno de mis
amigos me dijo bueno tal vez seas
asexual y yo lo busqué en google y dije
soy esto sí y me ofreció un poco vengas
a sentir que algo andaba mal conmigo
sabes yo sí pienso mucho en ello
pero lo pensaba mucho más cuando no
estaba absteniendo de ya saben el porno
y la masturbación en lugar de solo
pensar en eso e ir a masturbarme o
buscar a alguien con quien hacerlo yo
hago pilates y literalmente solo medito
y solo me concentro en canalizar ese
deseo sexual con el que todos nacemos y
lo que analizo hace algo que realmente
me beneficia como hacer vídeos de
youtube yo pienso más constantemente en
encontrar la pareja adecuada para mí en
encontrar el chico adecuado para una
relación he tenido decepciones muy malas
con algunas personas y simplemente no
quiero sentir que no soy
solo quiero sentirme valioso para
alguien fuera de sólo mi familia nuestra
cultura se centra en la virginidad de
las mujeres más que en la de los hombres
321 ahora
no tengo idea lo leo de nuevo no no yo
solo no lo sé siento que los hombres son
más elogiados cuando son vírgenes y que
la gente les presta más atención cuando
lo son como si fuera importante cuando
crecía las las personas que me enseñaron
ponían mucha presión en eso de
mantenerte pura o como saben para
cubrirte como mujer por el bien de los
hombres siento que somos vistas como
promiscuas si lo hacemos o como mojigata
si no lo hacemos si contrarrestaría eso
diciendo que para un chico es como que
sucede contigo si sigues siendo virgen
mientras que si ya no eres virgen es
como bueno finalmente ya estás en
nuestro equipo ya eres normal ahora de
acuerdo así que nos humillan como quien
es este sujeto sabes que ese daría paso
a por ti hermano me moveré es cierto así
que las mujeres las avergüenzan por
acostarse con alguien y a los hombres
por no hacer exactamente eso están mal
especialmente cuando los chicos adultos
vírgenes son ridiculizados y les dicen
cosas como que porque no tienes novia
porque no te vas a casar pronto o
eres un incierto quiero decir es solo
una dinámica diferente cuando se trata
de ser ridiculizado siendo mujer
comparado a cuando eres hombre
ser virgen está ligado a mi religión
321 ahora
es mi decisión pero está muy ligada a mi
catolicismo y a la que nos enseñan sobre
los sagrados sobre la santidad del
cuerpo y del alma y el valor que tiene
tu virginidad no sólo desde es un
sentido estrictamente biológico sino el
hecho de que estás dispuesto a esperar y
estás dispuesto a posponer algo que el
mundo está tratando de imponerte al ser
virgen no es parte de la religión en
teoría todas dicen no al sexo
prematrimonial si no eres religiosa
entonces tal vez tu individualidad no
esté ligada a tus creencias yo no soy
religiosa no voy a la iglesia tanto como
debería pero es mi decisión no es algo
religioso para mí a mi modo de ver dios
nos puso aquí por una razón y la mayoría
de la gente no sigue esas razones pero
los pocos que lo hacen son recompensados
por seguir el camino correcto así que yo
lo veo casi como una especie de
superpoder es como dios diciendo oye
estás de mi lado estás haciendo mi
trabajo estás caminando por el buen
camino buen trabajo es como si fueras a
ser si quería decir que el sexo crea
nueva vida entonces sí está absteniendo
de eso no se lo vas a dar a cualquiera
esto es un superpoder porque se queda
dentro de ti y puedes aprender a
controlarlo y canalizar esa energía
sexual a través de diferentes medios
puedes invertir más esfuerzos en la
escuela en tu trabajo una pasión un
pasatiempo en lugar de que se quede solo
como energía sexual sí aunque creo que
apoyarse en esa respuesta de es por mi
religión es decir mantenerte fiel a lo
que crees sobre cualquier cosa no sólo
el sexo puede ser muy difícil porque
somos humanos saben así que si es
natural es humana si el suelo tener la
excusa o el razonamiento de la religión
no nos lo hace más fácil un aplauso
hemos terminado
ah